اهلا بكم في الفقره الانسانيه لهذا اليوم
من امام احد المخابز هنا في مدينه دير
البلح حيث يتكدس الالاف من المواطنين هنا
لاستلام ربطه خبز واحده مدينه دير البلح
بداخلها ما يقارب من نصف مليون نازح فقط
اثنين من المخابز يعمل على مدار الساعه
لتلبيه احتياجات هؤلاء المواطنين وزاره
الاعلام والمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي قال بان
ما يقارب من
148 مخبز في قطاع غزه تم تدمير في هذه الح
20 مخبزا بشكل كامل بالاضافه الىى ذلك في
هذه الاوقات يعمل ما يقارب من 15 مخبزا
على مستوى القطاع اثنين في دير البلح
بالاضافه الى 13 مخبزا في منطقه جنوب قطاع
غزه حيث محافظه رفح الذي تقتض تماما
باعداد كبيره جدا من المواطنين في هذه
الاوقات المواطنون هنا يصطفون وبط وابير
كبيره جدا لاستلام ربطه خبز واحده وباث
مان قليله منظمه الاغاثه العالميه تقوم
بتوفير الطحين والسولار لهذه المخابز هنا
جمعيه اصحاب المخابز في قطاع غزه تتحدث عن
ايضا صعوبه في وصول الطحين والسولار لهذه
المخابز التي تعمل على مدار الساعه لتلبيه
احتياجات المواطنين السيد عبد الناصر
العجرمي وهو رئيس جمعيه اصحاب المخابز كيف
تقيمون عمل المخابز في هذه الاق يعني
بتعرف المخابز مهما عمل لن تلبي احتياجات
المواطن لانه اعدادها محدوده والمواطن
اليوم كل قطاع غزه اصبح يعتمد على الريف
الخبز الجاهز لعدم وجود بدائل يعني لا في
غاز ولا في كهرب ولا في سولار عند المواطن
عشان يمارس عمليه الخبيز في البيت فاصبح
اعتماده كلي على المخابز المخابز لن تلبي
احتياجاته لانه الطلب كبير ر فييوم تقريبا
منطقه دير البلح بتنتج مليون ريك في اليوم
ولكن الاحتياجات تتج ال 2 مليون ريف لكي
تلبي احتياجات دير البلاح كل يوم زي هيك
والله امرا كنت اطلع اذان الصبح عشان
الخبز وما اجيب اروح وقولنا فيش فيش فيش
طحين فيشي معناه معناه كثير من يوم تنا
بنع لا في حطب لا في طحين عند الواحد لا
في حاجه كل حاجه بدك تشترك للحطب ما بتكفي
طبخه ما بتكفي عج والله من يوم الحرب ما
عندي نفه غاز نفه غاز ما عندي ايش الواحد
يسوي اش ابو عمره الجزيره دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه